pascal drouhaud merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on l'a vu
au brésil au chili en bolivie ou encore
en équateur les protestations se
multiplient alors oui pour des raisons
différentes
néanmoins est ce qu'il y a des points
communs de ces pays d'amérique du sud
qui ont été révélées par la crise
sanitaire
il est certain que l'amérique latine
elle est totalement diverses et on voit
bien que la diversité se vérifie dans la
crise du coc vide de l'aco vie de dix
neuf qui frappe le continent ceci étant
il ya des éléments d'unité et est en
effet la fragilité des systèmes
sanitaires dans l'ensemble des pays vous
l'avez rappelé notamment au brésil au
pérou au mexique chili ou argentine
explique cette tension sociale qui
marque actuellement ces pays alors au
brésil 1 on a vu ces manifestations anti
confinement beaucoup critiquent la
politique de jaillir wolson à eau mais
aussi beaucoup la soutiennent qui sont
ces populations à qui parle le président
brésilien
alors il est vrai que l'on est là aussi
dans un débat on va dire idéologique
malgré tout au brésil ceci étant le
brésil un état fédéral
donc le président s'oppose en effet à
des mesures de déconfinement qui ont été
imposées établi par des les gouverneurs
d'état je pense notamment à sao paulo et
évidemment à rio à l'état de rio il
s'adresse à son électorat
il s'adresse à un électorat en disant
moi ce que je veux défendre c'est
l'économie et la santé
suivra donc il a essayé d'inscrire
véritablement le débat entre eux et le
combat son combat politique entre
l'économie qui générerait si la
situation devait empirer plus de
pauvreté donc mettrai plus en danger la
population que la santé je rappelle ce
dossier tant que actuellement le brésil
est touché par à peu près 200 41000 le
cas
deux personnes contaminées et à ce jour
compte seize mille deux cent dix huit
morts mais il est vrai que la crise
sanitaire que traverse le brésil qui est
en train de devenir véritablement
l'épicentre de la crise en amérique
latine
even révèle à la fois des fractures
politiques mais révèle aussi des
fractures sociales dans les états
regardez ce qui se passe notamment dans
l'état d'amazonas et notamment à manaus
qui devient un des lieux de pique
aujourd'hui de l'aco vie 10,9 au brésil
alors on a vu également ses
manifestations au chili alors que
vendredi dernier le président sebastian
pinera a ordonné un confinement dans la
région de la capitale santiago
des populations là encore qui craignent
des répercussions économiques très forte
dans le pays on sait que le pays et elle
a déjà été secoué par une grave grave
crise sociale et économique
quelles conséquences de cette pandémie
aujourd'hui au chili alors vous avez
raison de rappeler le contexte c'est
vrai qu'en fin de 2019 le chili compte
d'autres pays d'ailleurs été traversé
par des manifestations par une tension
sociale extrêmement forte et qui va
avait en fait enflammé le débat
politique
aujourd'hui la cofidis neuf et donc la
présence du virus ne peut que contribuer
à renforcer ce malaise un malaise
actuellement sanitaires et qui révèle là
aussi des faiblesses social et il est
évident que le déconfinement qui
s'annonçait puisque ces pays commence à
parler d'un déconfinement la fin du mois
ou courant juin vont évidemment replacer
le débat sur un terrain politique
ces pays le brésil mais le chili vous le
dit
l'équateur demain ou le pérou
notamment sont en effet engagés dans un
débat politique qui avait déjà enflammé
les rues en fin d'année et qui n'attend
que la période du déconfinement pour à
nouveau enflammé alors replacer le débat
sur un champ politique justement à ce
que l'épidémie a été l'occasion de voir
émerger de nouvelles figures politiques
à être capable de susciter de l'espoir
dans la population
alors je dirais surtout que l'aco vie de
10,9 et l'attendait mis en amérique
latine qui est actuellement sa sont
encore plonger totalement dans la crise
révèle surtout des fractures des
tensions dans à la fois la gouvernance
avec une diversité du continent et donc
une diversité de réaction je prends pour
exemple notamment de salvador où le
président mugabe est engagée depuis
quelques jours dans un bras de rapport
de force avec le parlement sous prétexte
justement de de fixer de nouvelles
mesures sanitaires
mais là attention vous l'avez
parfaitement montré existe au brésil
elle est récurrente dans l'arc du
pacifique ces pays de l'alliance du
pacifique qui vont du chili en remontant
au mexique
quid du venezuela qui compte peu de cas
mais dont on sait très bien que les
instruments de mesure aujourd'hui ne
sont pas très fiables
donc voilà donc il ya en fait une
diversité qui a montré
ceci étant une unité dans la
problématique sanitaire dans la
fragilité sociale je rappelle que
l'amérique latine 600 millions
d'habitants ce sont deux mains et la
cipale l'a rappelé dernièrement près de
34% de la population qui va vivre qui
vivent déjà dans la pauvreté
c'est à peu près 200 millions de
personnes donc c'est ça la réalité
sociale c'est ça la réalité économique
l'amérique latine c'est à la fois des
pôles de développement
gigantesque formidable des mégalopoles
comme são paulo ou mexico tout à fait
incroyable et en même temps des pôles de
sous-développement de pauvreté et je
crois que la pandémie va accélérer le
choc entre ces deux mondes
comme nous sommes déjà en train de voir
merci beaucoup pascal droux d'avoir
partagé votre expertise sur notre
antenne je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association lattes francs
et vice-président de l'institut choiseul